Because that light
was slowly drawing closer to the ship.
What appeared
before the astonished sailors...
Was...
-...a glittering dragon!
-a glittering dragon!
Amazing...
Everyone, look port side!
What is it?
Is that...?
I can't believe it.
Crocco!
-Yeah, I see it.
-Let's hunt it!
Are you kidding?!
In the middle of a storm?
How are we supposed to hunt it?
We have to hurry or it'll get away!
Are you crazy?!
Just bring the ship closer!
-I can't do that!
-Move, Mika!
Crocco, the dragon will lead us to safety!
We'll be able to make it out of the storm!
Are you serious?
It's possible the dragon would know
to avoid the storm clouds!
Sounds interesting.
We should trust him.
Captain, we'd make a huge profit
if we hunted that dragon!
That's enough!
Giraud, hold down the fort here.
Hey, Mika?